foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong I am Mark Ellis joined as always
by my co-host Jacqueline Coley and we
had a therapy breakthrough we did talk
about our pets you know what when you
don't have kids that's where the
projections go this is according to your
therapist well I just yeah according to
my therapist I mean I don't think my
therapist would say you had a
breakthrough because of your dog
therapist would say it was because of my
tutelage and guidance but you know it
was partially because of my dog so we're
raising our pets we're childless people
so we're raising our pets based on how
we were raised and the traumas that you
had as a as a child you will pass them
on to your children if you do not repair
them in therapy and if those children
happen to have four legs guess what they
still get it because they know what's up
I've long been a proponent if you want
kids out there just think about it and
maybe get a pet first and just practice
some stuff on them seriously they joke
about that practice on your goldfish
they joke about that but honestly I
question now parents that don't get pets
first I'm like you need some more
experience with this you need to
gradually work your way up to minor
leagues before you're ready for the show
and in terms of movies in the year we're
really in sort of the midst of these
show especially for you because we're in
the heat of awards season which I'm told
in my ear now means that more good
movies are coming out and being seen by
the masses hopefully seen by the mass
says I would just say anyone that can
hear the sound of my voice go see a
Prestige movie in a theater please
continue my livelihood there's been some
very troubling news in the trades but
yeah no it is it is Awards season sort
of the fruits of the seeds that we
planted in September or if you want to
say it back in May it can those are
finally coming to fruition these films
are now out people are voting on them
and that you know just yesterday morning
we had the Golden Globes announcements
on that sort of stuff so it's the time
of year to be reflective on the year's
best yeah we love our holiday movies
here we've talked a lot about that on
the show it's been a great year for
Rotten Tomatoes it's wrong really
because we've gotten to I think write a
lot of wrongs and maybe talk about some
movies that were a little too highly
rare than Tomato Meter but now we're
here to celebrate our top 10 movies of
the year so here's the way it's going to
work is that we have part one is going
to be five of Jaclyn's favorite movies
and five of my favorite movies and then
we have part two that's gonna be coming
out a week from now and that is going to
be Jack other half of her top ten and
Mark's other half of his top 10 but we
made the command decision to not attach
numbers no to the movies because we've
been harmed yes we are wise beyond our
years and honestly if you're making
movie reviews or movie like commentary
type stuff as this man has done for a
long time and I've done for a long time
respectively then you know
that anytime you put any kind of like
gauge out there people will light you up
with it forever any amount of time like
oh you gave that three stars what about
this and you're like well that was a
hard three stars this was a soft three
star you know what I mean you end up
having to do that and I don't want
people coming for me because I decided
that you know x movie and not the movie
X by Ty West I'm just saying blank movie
you had a good year you did have a good
year is rated higher than the movie that
you decided to make your entire
personality like I I don't have that
kind of fight in me how is tax higher
rated than Pearl and they get so mad I
still hear from people who I gave 13
hours the Michael Bay classic I gave
that 5 out of five schmo's back when
when we were doing Schmo snow and I
stand by it I saw the movie twice in
theaters thought it was awesome and uh I
gave it five out of five so but any time
after that a movie would come out that I
really liked and I would say you know
like Thor Ragnarok I'm like yeah it was
good four and a half out of five shows
I'd get a comment that says oh so it's
not as good as 13 hours and I'm like oh
my God really look we're we're not
assigning numbers to these I will say at
the end of episode two of this two-part
companion piece I will say what my
favorite movie of the year is you will
say what's your favorite movie of the
year yes which may be a different movie
than one my versus episode of the best
movies of 2022 because that's a whole
different thing so we have a lot to get
to today we have a lot to disseminate
but we're here to celebrate our favorite
movies of the year what we don't have is
uh two minutes with Tim because Tim
according to my Intel Tim has seen three
movies this year uh that are in Tim does
have small children they're in glorious
Technicolor I think he's seen a lot of
cartoons I think he's seen a lot of
Blues Clues a lot of PJ masks he saw
Thor we know that and we saw black
panther wakanda forever and then he said
the rest of the movies that he watched
were all in black and white so good for
you Tim we're proud of you we love you
uh shout out to our editorial team as
well the best movies of 2022 ranked by
Tomato Meter you can find that on the
website rottentomatoes.com as well as
folks like Jacqueline and others can
contributing to the awards leaderboard
and that is also going to be
rottentomatoes.com so check on that one
that way you will know who's supposed to
be the winner even if they don't end up
winning I love having you as my partner
in crime here because you saw so many
more movies than I did and you
and you're gonna give your favorite
movie
um I am not
again because this is dangerous
territory if any of you are wondering
we'll make this a little we're gonna
take a little after dark Segway which by
the way if you guys listen to our after
dark episode please do it's the best
thank you it was so much fun we want to
do more of those so please listen to
that episode make it higher than like
Harry Potter there's a whole lot more in
our closet I mean really anyway so if
you do these lists then everybody wants
to like come at you like there was
literally just somebody the New York
Times this guy puts out his 10 best of
lists and people are coming for him in
the comments like they stole his first
he stole their first board and I just
don't want that kind of smoke also I
might add besides the internet masses
that both Mark and I as public figures
face I also face the people sometimes
involved in these movies who are not
exactly pleased or maybe they're
publicist but sometimes the people in
the movies like you got actors you got
you got directors you have performed you
have Union crew people that would be
coming up to me and like I don't want
Gene and Prince by the wood looking at
me any kind of way
any for like I'm just kidding she
wouldn't care she's way too cool for
that but you know what I mean it's
mostly the publicist the publicist would
be like why didn't you rank us higher
look everybody going back to our opening
with the therapy and how you were raised
every kid wants to be mentioned first in
the Christmas letter yes every kid wants
that honor even though from now for my
stand-up days I realized that my mom
only lists me last because that means
I'm the headliner which is what I tell
my sister and my brother that sounds
like a good way to transition into movie
talk
foreign
because you are a watcher of so many
movies and I I saw a fair amount of
movies this year I think just
comparatively with years past when I was
like reviewing everything
everywhere all at once I would see like
hundreds of movies right and now I saw a
good chunk of movies I saw more of the
movies I wanted to see and I think my
list is going to reflect that but there
are some sort of out of the Mark Ellis
box that you all have put me in I'm fine
but I I think that there's some movies
that might surprise some people yeah on
my list how was the 2022 movie year for
you overall I think the 22 it's
surprising I would say the movies that
resonated with me this year were ones
that just spoke to me personally like
this was a year where I was very much
less concerned with like what this
person thought with that movie not
saying that I ever am but I think some
years there was this thing of like oh
well I've gotta support this one kind of
thing or like legitimately like where
it's like okay I didn't love this but
but you want to show up for it but I
want to show up for it and this year I
was just like what did I like dig like
what did I think was cool like what was
I like thinking and feeling and what's
really funny too is for the first time
in a long time the moments that I really
sort of keyed in on a lot of them were
on television this year which was really
surprising for me because so many of the
movies that I enjoyed that are even on
this list they all gave me something
that I wanted but very few of them gave
me something that I didn't know I wanted
so what's interesting is that when I
submitted my 10 movies to producer Brian
they were all documentaries and he said
Mark you can't do time they're all
documentaries that I watched at home by
myself and they're about boring topics
like the building of a bridge like I'm
really boring now but there were enough
movies and I feel like 2022 you know we
were coming out of the pandemic people
were excited to be back in theaters
there are a couple movies that really
revved our engines and we're like oh
this is why we love going to movies and
so my list reflects some of those bigger
films that got new demographics back
into theater going mode but then there's
some other stuff that's just so tiny and
so small that I feel like it was a good
mix of everything and I feel like the
awards season is starting to come to
play uh in full force it really is
what's really interesting too is that
this year more than any year there was a
lot of I think movies that everyone
thought was going to be that ish that
didn't end up being and a lot of really
like surprising movies like I mean look
the one we just saw Avatar I think a lot
of people were like okay it's James
Cameron
I'm going in like and there's a lot of
people being like yeah he did that like
you know what I mean like people people
are having intense like existential like
moments of intimacy with fish with a
whale with the you know what I mean you
know what I mean like with sea mammals
people are literally like losing their
mind and they did not expect that going
into the blue people movie I hope Avatar
pops up on one of our lists because I
have thoughts so I hope so let's get
let's get started with our list so again
these are five movies from Jacqueline
and five for me that are in our top ten
of the Year we're not gonna rank them
because of feelings but we're gonna go
to you first you get to kick off what is
your first movie in your top 10 of 2022
okay this is another one that just I
think speaks to me and I will go ahead
and fully admit it and that is bones and
all this is the Timothy chalamet Luca
guadinino uh Taylor Russell film they
star in why a cannibal love story who
doesn't warm their hearts thinking about
it well Taylor Russell basically plays a
young girl who's been raised by her
father despite this Affliction that she
has which is basically that she wants to
eat people and it's something that he
tries to keep in check but obviously
it's very clear that they often have to
like pack up and leave like she gets
into these situations where she ends up
basically anytime she's unguarded with
other people she ends up losing it and
eating them and so he has to keep her on
a tight lock so it's like a more
dramatic the Santa Clarita diet yeah
remember that show it is
wow these people right yes and honestly
you have made this movie so you really
did exactly it really is it was a good
it was a it was a critically acclaimed
audience enjoyed the show the Santa
Clarita diet so but look I will say this
I haven't seen the movie yet man you
really took the juice out of this though
in that way and the way that I have to
like wow in a way that I have to admit
that like you just told the perfect joke
about my movie to where like now I can't
even say any good thing about it because
you're like this is an artsy Santa
Clarita diet and you know what you're
right I didn't I didn't set this up to
where I'm just gonna crap on every one
of Jaclyn's picks and aren't in my top
ten I'm gonna applaud you for it you did
it so well I know you love your your
nephew Timothy chalamet but I will also
say what really intrigues me and why I
want to see this movie is the
combination of him and Luca guadalino
because I thought call me by your name
yeah was so fantastic and I think that
was in my top ten of that year yes look
I can I can rebound it is very Rihanna
Calvin Harris We Found Love in a
hopeless place it is very bad so like
whereas in with Santa Clarita diet this
was his wife and then he finds out
something whatever he loved her already
this was like something different that
happened to her with these two they're
both Afflicted and they're finding
Community with each other these two very
isolated people who happen to be
cannibals can find a way despite the
reality that they're living like if you
change gained the cannibalism to drug
addiction
you can see how this movie really sort
of plays differently it's really about
these two people that are in the worst
versions of themselves finding better
versions of themselves which is still
probably not great together okay what's
our uh what's our scores uh this one's
82 and 61 audience score I will say I'm
sure a lot of Timmy fans didn't know
about all the eating this is what's so
weird why girls who will be scr in my
generation were screaming bite me Rob
Patterson at every chance they get are
now squeamish at the thought that he
wants to eat the the stuff that's around
the blood he's literally drinking your
blood but that's sexy but if he wants to
like chew into it no that's really great
you would feel like we as a society have
now been raised to accept not
cannibalism but the fact that there's
gonna be protagonists that we can root
for that have a tendency to eat people
or suck their blood based on the
Twilight movies and all of this other
what we do in the shadows like with
vampires they're not just evil they can
be funny they can be uh studious they
can go to college I think what it is
with vampires is I get why it's
different it's like you're bringing an
essence of yourself that can be
replenished and it's not like you know
it's not far from the realm of
possibility that that is something that
you can exchange with somebody and it's
not gross right that's like a thing
but not not very often do people like
give you parts of their body that the
other person eats yeah it's a little
weird and once you get into the real
graphic depiction of it the uh the
tearing of the tissue
on the marrow but they're not doing it
to each other I'm just saying that like
hey if these are the things these two
people do you know what I mean like it's
like again with all these vampire love
stories they aren't always like you know
eating each other now I know where that
movie's called Bones and all I did not
know I saw the poster I've seen the
poster and the Billboards all over town
so they're they're making a push with
this thing are we looking at Oscar bait
it's not bait it's just it's they know
what they're eating
it's one like it got nominated for a
couple gothams it won um I believe
a couple of like the top 10 or MBR or
something like that it was on like a
couple of uh a couple of good
nominations it got a bunch of Indie
Spirit nominations that's what it was
okay well bones and all uh proof that
hitchhiking is dangerous for both
parties hitchhiking is you never know
what car you're getting into honestly
you know that's fair this movie does
teach you a bit of that not in the way
that you think but absolutely that's
what I'm saying well look for my for for
my first movie to kick off here it's a
movie that also is about eating people
uh Kai well it's more about hunting
people and that is just if the current
planet that you're hunting for sport on
is inhabited by people I am of course
talking about prey the prequel to
Predator that was I guess I'm allowed to
do this even though it went straight to
a streaming service so it I don't know
if it works for the Oscars it works for
Mark Ellis and his list and I love this
movie I this was everything that I
wanted Shane Black's the Predator to be
and was not this felt like a true
prequel but it also felt like it
furthered the Predator war and I mean
who would have put money on the fact
that okay well the the theatrical
release so we put a lot of resources
behind and it didn't really get a lot of
people interested back in Predator now
this Hulu movie suddenly you're like I
want a predator in every historical time
period you cannot tell me that you would
not pay a lot of money to go see Jesus
and his Apostles take on a predator oh
my God they can Assassin's Creed
Predator absolutely like do this in yeah
absolutely Julius Caesar versus a
Predator I don't know about Julius but
like look Victorian I can see that being
interesting you know what I mean
Cleopatra woo a predator hey look Wild
West type stuff I can see that look at
your face oh my God Young Guns three we
just wrote it Billy the Kid probably
Billy the adult now taking on the
Predator Billy versus Predator
but this movie blew me away and it was
so well depicted and I love the way that
they that they that you you get to see
the story of this young woman who wants
to be a warrior that's not her carved
out role in this you know indigenous
people but she fights she's the heart of
a warrior you know she has a dog
Coco's the name of the actor dog yeah
and it's just a magnificent movie and
you get to see not just Predators you
get to see cougar attacks you get to see
Bears there's some bison involved
there's a lot going on in this movie can
I go ahead and say that I know this is
your favorite movie but can I say this
if the dog didn't make it
it couldn't have been your favorite
movie you know now we're starting to get
back to killing the dog more and I don't
like the trend in cinema I think John
Wick kind of sparked that back but I
ended up liking John Wick because the
rest of the movie lived up to it so
it would have been hard but I would I
would have understood
it is uh 93 certified fresh on the
Tomato Meter 73 audience score so that's
a little curious I mean I think that one
a little bit it's first of all it's on
Hulu so we can't verify it like we can
with the stuff that goes into theaters
sure but the one thing I will also say
with this one is
there's just gonna be certain people
whereas in if you're going to be there's
an argument to be made for at one point
Arnold Schwarzenegger was the person
fighting this and now we have Amber I
believe it's Thundercloud uh fighting
this and there's some people that that
just glitches them that does glitch them
and they just then go and take it out on
the score not fair not fair at all
because if you remember the first
Predator Arnold defeated the Predator
not with his muscles and with guns but
with just hiding in the mud and just
waiting for the right opportunity just
waiting for the weakness yeah fine in
the moment uh the other thing I just
wanted to add before we leave pray
because I think that Amber is going to
be on a lot of young performer lists
like the Critics Choice Awards uh which
are going to be announced to well by the
time this airs actually
um they will have already been announced
but I think she's going to be somebody
that we see a lot more of both her and
Katie divery from uh reservation dogs
are two indigenous performers that I'm
just like whatever you guys have going
on I really just want to see more of it
because they've already shown in their
first projects like just put them on
Amber Amber mid Thunder mid Thunder
thank you foreign
next up actually on my list this is
another example of it's just something
that speaks to me although I do think
this is like an actually really great
film and very Mark material if you
haven't seen this one I would be
surprised so this one is actually the
story and the guy that made it it was
not his intention to star into airplane
movies in the same year but there was
this little pandemic thing that made it
happen and this story it's the second of
the two and it's the story of two Korean
Air Force pilots including Jesse Brown
who was the very first Naval aviator who
happened to be African-American and the
trials that he went through to become an
aviator
um literally had to be the best just for
them to give him a chance and Glenn
Powell stars in that alongside Jonathan
Majors they are brilliant and it is such
such a good film plays so well directed
by JD Dillard who came up through like
the Bad Robot era and I was and he was
actually his father was a Naval aviator
so he's a black wow Aviator son and the
first time I saw it as I was like oh
this is definitely gonna be something I
talk about in theory because my father
was a Navy man grandfather was like in
Pearl Harbor very much raised in
military families and so like I was like
and it's very much about like Fathers
and Sons devotion right yeah devotion
because it's about the love and devotion
you have for your country for your wife
because in this and I just have to put
out here
um Jessie sort of how they sort of have
come to understand him as the man is
that his wife showed her letters that he
would write to her while he was in
training you know they had to fight
really hard to keep her on base near him
also they told him not to get married
before he went to flight school he was
like forget that I love her I'm gonna
marry her and then it made it difficult
and when he was in Korea he was writing
her and those most devoted letters like
I would walk a thousand oceans to be
near you the letters from wartime past
oh my God that's just unbelievable Pros
like you cannot tell me how can you
listen to that and then listen to some
dude that can only like text you at the
end of the night WYD you know what I
mean like he was a great comedian Greg
Giraldo had a fantastic bit Tom pop and
I were in The Green Room economy store
we were reciting the bit to each other
Papa was good friends with with geralda
before he passed and he just had a great
bit about how like the war letters from
back in the day were so different than
the world letters she get now yeah
that's all I'll leave for today but it
it this is a movie I I wanted to see
yeah simply because I'm a fan of
Jonathan majors and Glenn Powell you see
him in Top Gun Maverick obviously as
hangman and then he comes into this and
it's like this guy's just a great
Aviator but Jonathan Majors he's more
than just a bodybuilder okay yeah that I
mean what he's done with that body I
mean pretty impressive can I tell you I
interviewed him it's so embarrassing I
interviewed him and it's like I just
like looked at his Men's Health spread
because he does talk about movie stuff
in there too but it's like you have to
like I felt like a guy for the first
time to be like I see how this is
distracting like and how you can get
kind of rageful about it because like
I'm a journalist I'm trying to like
concentrate on things and all I'm
thinking about is what did you do to do
what you do that's all I would ask if I
did the junket for that movie yeah I
would literally just have him put me
through my Paces I'm like just show me
the exercises you did give me the
printout of of your daily diet like like
Michael B Jordan when he was getting in
shape and by the way we get to see
Jonathan Majors yeah
that's the way I was like interviewing
for devotion but I was like just
thinking I was like it's underneath
there yeah it's gonna be a slug fashion
Creed Three I I can't wait to see that
one um I want to go over to your list
but real quick on devotion uh 81
certified fresh and this is a 91
audience score so the audience knows
what's up on this one and that's the
thing I want to tell people this is a
great movie to watch with your family
especially if you grew up in a military
your family okay well I you know you
talk about airplane movies and uh the
gentleman who is the subject of this
next movie on my list uh which is 77
certified fresh with the Tomato Meter
but 94 of the audience score so again
the audience those was up this gentleman
is famous for hopping on an airplane
from time to time just so he could go
down to Memphis and get himself a deep
fried peanut butter and banana sandwich
that would be Elvis Elvis Presley The
Redneck with with so much talent he has
just redneck energy if I had a private
plan all to myself I'd probably be
taking it back east and taking myself to
Bojangles once a week I do not have that
luxury yet Elvis Presley did he lived a
life and Colonel Tom Parker is sort of
the conduit the way that we're telling
this story played by Tom Hanks Austin
Butler is the reason why this movie's on
my top 10 list and because if you're
looking at performances of the year the
whale was like an honorable mention for
me just because Brendan Fraser is that
good in it yeah and and the rest of to
the cast that movie is too but this one
it's not only a guy playing Elvis but
he's also on stage being Elvis I mean
Austin Butler I don't know if he's
gotten rid of Elvis since he filmed the
movie and Tom Hanks is always great and
it's just it's interesting it was the
way that I heard about this movie is
that it's weird that it's Colonel Tom
Parker being the one to tell the story
and I'm like well yeah I'm showing up to
see an Elvis movie why do I want Colonel
Tom because I know that that I know that
tale and how that ends but I found it to
be an interesting different kind of
biopic and it really resonated with me
particularly the musical performances I
don't think you're wrong about that one
I'm not an Elvis Defender but I'm not an
Elvis denier I'm right there I'm right
I'm right there with you so like my
thing with Elvis um which that's
beautifully said by the way also I just
want to add uh really quickly I love
that you have this on your list because
I feel like this is that movie this year
like it's very Bohemian Rhapsody where
it's like people are putting their lines
where they stand on this one and it's
unfortunate I thought it can and I saw
how that movie played it and it
continues to play since then so like I
get it bazlerman can Mesmerize an
audience he can like literally whip
magic into an audience he can literally
Dazzle them when you thought it can
because that's the film festival famous
well like a few other ones are for you
know the 30-minute standing ovations or
whatever but the audience is really get
excited they get Jews from seeing these
movies what was it like being in the
crowd at Elvis were people just like
dancing in the aisles were they losing
their minds they weren't losing their
minds but like you have to remember this
was the crowd that when Brad Pitt took
off his shirt and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood they clap so did I and they
also had a very similar reaction to like
the Elvis performance scene okay you
know what I mean like it was very like
we're gonna clap for this because that's
how good it is to where you'll miss like
parts of the movie because they're still
applauding this like set piece which is
kind of fun to be an environment like
that even if you got to go back and
watch and pick up another line that you
missed that the Applause drowned out
absolutely and that's what I mean when I
say bazlerman is like a magician when it
comes to like audiences like he'd like
he wields this magic and the thing he
really like got people to understand was
the way that Elvis sort of beamed sex
into American homes for the very first
time like this was the first time girls
thought of like oh what is he doing with
his legs like legitimately they were so
innocent up until that point I love that
quote from uh from Billy Joel who was
interviewed years ago and he's like well
the fact that when he was on The Ed
Sullivan Show and they made the command
decision to not show him from the waist
down that made it even more intriguing
yes so they actually because if you just
saw him do his dance it was like well
this guy's a talented performer but you
can't see what's going on and so
everybody in America was like what the
hell's happening down there that's even
more it's the mystery of it ticket sales
just like jacked up and jacked up and I
know you were big on Elvis just as far
as him probably being considered for
like some of the top Awards right top
awards for this one definitely best
actor the one that I think people are
like not thinking about it as opposed to
Brendan Fraser who I'm glad you shot it
out I do think he's great in the whale
Elvis is that girl though and Austin
Butler is absolutely
um the one to play it I just love this
for baz because he's just
been plucking away with this and also
shout out to Denzel Washington who
apparently was responsible for Austin in
a lot of ways keeping or getting the
role like Austin Austin was in the
process of it maybe or like maybe he had
been already having conversations and
and he had done a play with Denzel the
Iceman Cometh and when he watched Denzel
do that play Denzel saw Austin was like
this kid's really good and he told baz
he's like you should make him your Elvis
like don't keep him waiting like you
should do this and that's what kind of
gave bass and like because you know when
things when you can't get the money yeah
you start thinking well who can we get
where we can get the money yeah then he
ended up being the red choice and he
ended up being the right choice but I'm
sure if you don't think there was a
studio saying well why don't we give it
to this person yeah I'm sure but then
Denzel he carries a lot of weight in
Hollywood exactly like saying because I
think obviously he had won it on the
audition but it's more than on audition
to take that role you got to do a lot he
got into that character man
you got into it anyway moving on to my
side Let's uh let's take a look oh yes
this is my next one again I feel like I
should have broken it up a little bit
because otherwise you're gonna feel I'm
like going very Starship Troopers with
it but
neither one of these are particularly
friendly to the US military so I will
say that this is the keeping with a
trend yeah this next one actually
current Golden Globe nominee for one of
the portrayals in this one this is
actually produced by a husband and wife
Duo as well as Stars the wife uh
somebody from a world you would
understand sir they are big family
people and you will recognize him
because of his time in Miami sending
home my Dallas Mavericks Dwayne Wade
Gabrielle Union I'm talking about the
inspection sir okay starring Jeremy Pope
which is directed by Elegance Bratton it
is his semi biography autobiographical
tale of his life in the military after
he was disowned by his mother for his
homosexuality he was living on the
street
joins the military when he turns 18.
in the time of don't ask don't tell
right right knowing that you know
they're like you can't be here if they
find out you're gay and he's just like
it's better than living on the street
wow so but he makes it he makes it
through uh he makes it through the
military he ends up being able to thrive
with it and then eventually becomes a
filmmaker and this is his story and it's
a24 it's beautiful It's haunting the
as far as like saying something
obviously about you know found families
and how there's ostracization due to
Faith and all of these other kinds of
things it's also just beautifully shot
Raul Castillo uh Rob Raul Castillo is in
it and he's like incredible in it and
Gabrielle Union literally gives like an
oscar-winning performance love love love
it 88 certified fresh 90 audience score
so what era does it take place in so
it's set I'm guessing in like the 90s
like late 90s early you know what I mean
because I think he was born in the 70s
so like you know it was still in don't
ask no telling dead ass no tell stopped
in like I think 2010 right right but it
was a big topic
debate in the 90s this was back when I
remember like dude from The Real World
had a guy that he was dating that was in
the military and they couldn't show him
on screen oh I don't remember that that
angle yeah like this was like New
Orleans year this guy named like Danny
he had a friend of his who the guy in
the star not friend the guy that he was
dating his boyfriend who's in the
military and he knew that you know and I
remember that they like blurred him out
and I just remember being like 16 and be
like I want to see his face and now I'm
like oh my God that was so dangerous
what was that kid doing you know what I
mean if you were to look at the like is
a boyfriend a friend is a girlfriend a
friend do they count like is it all is
trying to find them and then the the
boyfriend or the significant other is
like an offshoot of that or is I always
had it in a different box entirely you
know what maybe that's why I'm single
maybe it should be in a different box
entirely but the one thing I would say
is I do think it's like thumbs like all
boyfriends should be friends but not all
friends or boyfriends our thumbs fingers
yeah no oh yeah not according to Avatar
not according to Avatar they only look
at the tall digits they're not they
don't care about thumps in Avatar really
that's what they're saying they're like
you have four fingers and I'm looking at
it and I'm like I have five digits but
maybe I only have four fingers
and two thumbs that do this weird thing
I mean I think look
I saw
five
Story by credits and three writing
credits on this one let's give them a
break fingers in the thumbs okay but you
give thumbs up
to the inspection another one that I
think you would like because again it's
not about I mean not that you wouldn't
if if it was but because like I know
like for example you loved Bros um but
it's like it's much more about this kid
it's very like he has an impossible task
and you you very much feel from any like
this person is trying to make it through
a trial type show like shoot it's very
look it's very polyshore in the Army now
kind of stuff you know I remember the
scene yeah in in the Army now whereas
like you know because again that came
out in the 90s and so they're like okay
well if you say you're gay then kiss
each other and it's Andy Dick and Paulie
Shore and they just they just kiss them
and it's a scene mine for comedy back
then and it's like so something like the
inspection actually not for because I
saw it in the Army and also the idea
that they hate the military so much but
the idea of kissing each other they
literally could not do that to save
their existence like that is like worse
than comedy that's just stupidity yeah
like yeah toxic and then if they would
have gotten shot toxic masculinity
literally killed you
there you go literally you could adjust
you could have just like puckered up
yep pounded that out moved on lived your
life couldn't do it
couldn't do it back in the day we were
so stupid in the 90s this is a perfect
transition because Dwyane Wade and uh
and Gabrielle Union produced the
inspection I don't know if you know this
Dwyane Wade used to play basketball and
he was very good at it and this movie is
about basketball and it's called hustle
ah starring Adam Sandler we got 93
certified fresh
and 93 on the audience score I know a
little bit about this 93 on both metrics
and I mean this was a movie custom made
for somebody like myself I'm a huge NBA
fan I love basketball I still hoop all
the time as does Adam Sandler and he
plays a scout who works for the 76ers
who is really just concerned with some
ownership changes and Ben Foster what a
great another great villainous turn for
baby Foster in this movie where he's
sort of the heir to be but isn't ready
for the task of running the team yeah
and he's at odds with Adam Sandler So
Adam Sandler is just looking for this
next stud who's the next Dirk Nowitzki
who's the next Luka doncic who I can
really find and bring to the 76ers and
and get them back to complete the
process and actually win a championship
what a heartwarming story this movie
ended up being the basketball's great in
it the cameos are Non-Stop and it's a
really sweet movie and I think it's up
there with the best I've ever seen Adam
Sandler uh I don't disagree with you on
that one I also want to say I believe
this is a LeBron Adam Sandler sort of
like partnership production because I
believe this was done with there to with
their two companies together that makes
all the sense in the world after seeing
the picture multiple times because I
will say yeah you know it is uh it is a
cameo heavy one I did a I did a
conversation on this movie about it with
him and sort of talked about it he is so
proud of this thing like he is like yeah
because he's such a sports I mean this
is a guy that like there's not a lot of
Seasons where you won't catch them at
least more than a handful of games I
think he probably has like season
tickets he goes to games all the time he
still rolls up to random playgrounds
wherever he's shooting and we'll just
play pickup ball I mean the guy the
guy's a sports nut yeah and so for him
to be really in his version of Rudy is
is like so I think like a kid in a candy
store also the best joke in the entire
thing because of course it is still
funny is the fact that he hates soccer
like that is just such a good guy the
fact that he hates soccer because as a
basketball coach where he's playing
that's he's not losing losing them to
drugs on the corner he's losing them to
soccer moves them to soccer we always
say that in America the other way around
where it's like I mean you know if we
could get like LeBron and and Derrick
Henry and and our stars from other
leagues to just focus on soccer maybe
we'd be really good at soccer no the
joke is I actually saw this and I forget
it was Tick Tock but I believe it to be
true not the way you would on Tick Tock
but like this was so true that I would
believe it uh they were like if if the
black people that play basketball and
football in America all decided to just
start playing soccer look out Brazil
look at Argentina there would be no
World Cup it would be like the way it is
for us with basketball
it would be like the way it is for us
with basketball when we play olympically
the way that it used to be because it's
it's it's tough sledding in the Olympics
I mean we still are the favorite usually
with basketball but 92 the Dream Team
here look that was just we're coming to
collect gold medals do you guys want to
work we still have to fight for it I'm
not saying that they don't but again the
dominance is just the the athleticism is
just on another level it's it's the
problem is these other teams from other
countries they play together all season
long and we're just getting like our
well that's what I mean when I say
there's no World Cup in the sense that
like like as if America isn't good at
exports like come on they would be
playing in the English Premier League
like a lot of Americans already are
doing can I say something what I'm happy
they play football American football and
American basketball because I like those
Sports more would you would you what do
you watch I watch the World Cup
I watched the World Cup I play soccer
you would watch you would watch uh oh no
yeah you watch curling if it's the USA
put the flag on it
hell yeah is there any is there any
Olympic sport you would not want I'm
actually not a big Olympics guy
I watch so many other sports Jacqueline
but if somebody had a USA match on is
there anything that you would still say
no if I'm not a big figure I'm not a big
Olympic sport guy I'm really not so
there's anything basically I'll watch
the I'll watch the track and I'll watch
the basketball okay that's what I'm here
for that's fair and hustle um about
Hustle real quick is that it reminded me
of life on the road as a comedian
because there's shots of Adam Sandler's
Scout and he's in foreign countries and
he can't speak the language but he
always finds either a McDonald's or a
Pizza Hut and there's shots of him in
his hotel room just winding down with
that not trying not going out not seeing
the sights not trying this new
restaurant that you gotta have and it's
got this type of food he just wants his
comfort food because he's working too
hard and he misses his family and he's
just uh you know it's a he's working his
ass off but it's for a goal and he
believes in himself and uh who wouldn't
want to see a movie about that so there
you go this is very air up there this is
you this is you putting a little bit of
you in that one I'm putting a little bit
me and that so this is your fourth movie
this is my fourth movie yeah my fourth
movie of my five uh good luck to you Leo
Grande yes ladies and gentlemen my reign
as the thirstiest member of this podcast
continues because we have a two-hander
sex comedy and I did choose those words
wisely okay okay yeah no this is Emma
Thompson so even if I'm gonna do a sex
comedy I'm gonna make it cool yeah Evan
Thompson and Daryl McCormack they play a
sex worker Daryl and Emma Thompson a
widow who is trying to have her first
positive sexual experience because and
she quotes that she has been married to
the same man since she was 22 who would
you know not be very good in the bedroom
every night
um just do his little gyrating thing
kiss her on the cheek and she would sit
there like then he goes to watch the
Golf Channel you gotta know these things
before you get married I'm not telling
you all what to do with your wives I'm
just saying you might want to explore
that before you get married yeah and so
she existed in a very repressed very
judgmental sexual existence she was a
school teacher you can imagine how those
girls felt she finds out
um and so at the age of 70 something
she's just like you know I'm going to do
this and so she hires the sex worker
played by Daryl McCormack and he helps
her find herself but she finds herself
in her own self and it's just two people
in a room talking which is one of the
hardest types of Cinema to make but it
is the best type of Cinema to make and
you're not watching sex scenes like it's
it's very much a song and dance before
you actually ever even see them do
anything intimate oh okay so there's all
right what's the rating on this one we
going r r but just regular R and Emma
Thompson gives a literally career best
performance and the script is so very
very very smart and Daryl McCormack
holds his own with her it's it plays
very much like a play and it's on Hulu
and it's great what's our tomato Mater
93 certified fresh 85 audience go course
so the people that have seen they like
love it okay I I do need to see that
when I'm putting that one on my list to
watch yeah um we got about 10 minutes
left so let's burn through the rest of
these babies the unbearable way to
massive Talent is my fourth oh that's a
great one 27 certified fresh 87 audience
score I like movies that are the same on
both metrics and I mean what this one it
hooked everybody from the premise the
stick was cage playing himself this
feels like a movie that we could have
gotten 10 15 years ago with Nick Cage
and it would have worked the same yeah
but I think it works even better now
knowing Nick Cage but knowing that he
still has that I mean we saw him in pig
yeah we saw him in Joe so we've seen him
not just do the red box stuff but he
also really still has those chops yeah I
was just about to say he talked about
that because he said even on all those
crappy quote-unquote crappy movies that
he was a part of he was like I never
phoned it in no he didn't he was like
you gave me whatever premise you gave me
and I would give you everything that you
asked for as a as a Craftsman and he
said he like worked himself out of his
debt which I'm also like talk about some
like you know give it up for Italian
Pride like he's just like I'm just gonna
go break my back yeah and do what I need
to do and find his way back to it also I
think Mandy is the movie that I point to
the kick started him back Mandy's
another good a good one the guy can do
any genre he can do a range of stuff uh
Pedro Pascal plays a nefarious character
but maybe he's not all that nefarious
when you really break down the family
that he's in he's a big Nick Cage fan he
hires him to be himself at his birthday
party hilarity and zaniness ensues one
of my favorite parts of this movie is
when they're both they find they're High
um on many substances and Pedro Pascal
and Nicholas Cage just their facial
expressions when they're looking around
and they think they're in danger it is
just fall down funny it's really a fun
romp and if you're a Nick Cage fan at
all if you've ever seen a Nick Cage
movie you get that much more out of it
I'm really excited to see this one again
because I actually saw it man it was
literally like right when it came at
home I like have a DVD of it but the
only thing I really remember was Pedro
Pascal just cracking me up because he's
swaying that was like I'd seen him be
funny in Wonder Woman but that one was
the one where I was like oh no this
dude's like really funny yeah yeah you
don't really get a chance to do that
much in the mandalorians in the way of
Comedy not as much yeah and definitely
not you know House of not a sorry Game
of Thrones right not a not a hysterical
a whole lot of opportunity there yeah
all right so your final movie in this
just part one just part one Jacqueline
hasn't said your favorite movie yet you
still got a whole other episode a whole
another episode where I will also Dodge
the question
um my final one this is like everyone's
like yeah really we knew
um black panther wakanda forever I
really did love this movie I honestly
cannot say enough about how it was
better than I thought and this is what I
want to tell anyone who has a naysayer
sure whatever you were saying we hear
that did you have to rip up the movie in
the middle of it because your star died
no well then this is what you get like
it's like the Simone biles thing like
the difficulty level of just rewriting
this entire storyline and granted I'm
sure yes they borrowed elements but this
was not the way this was supposed to go
you know what I mean and I might be more
forgiving than most and maybe people I'm
sure everybody knew that we lost
Chadwick Boseman he was black panther
and now we really have to Pivot with
where we're taking this movie and this
mythology of wakanda and how does it fit
into the greater MCU that was my
favorite thing about this movie is it I
mean I went in I knew it was going to be
emotional because this movie had many
jobs like you said we had to honor the
legacy of Chadwick Boseman but then we
also have to set up who's gonna be our
next Panther yeah and then we also have
to be in this Marvel Cinematic Universe
and the way that it didn't really bother
yeah with all the other stuff that I
felt like phase four got bogged down in
and yes I'm talking about the
multiverses it didn't work you never
heard the word in this movie and that
was so refreshing what we did get that
was new new was Namor and all of his
underwater people and I thought that was
a really cool element to add into the
MCU and that felt a lot more natural and
not like forced sort of I hate saying
this word but I'm gonna say it so
everybody knows where I'm talking about
fan service yeah it just felt like that
was more real to me it's really
interesting too how contained wakanda
look the thing that is not supposed to
be there is probably a black Iron Girl
Riri Williams I'm like trying to like
remember the character's name um anyway
I don't remember the character's name
but Riri Williams
um she is coming in and that's like if I
had to say something that's a bit
ham-fisted her and like maybe what's
going on with Julia Dreyfus or Lake Bell
probably bigger elsewhere you know
that's probably like Secret Wars type
stuff you gotta plant some seeds but it
wasn't detracting yeah it wasn't
distracting and like again like he
didn't have a choice on that now would I
love to see and where I'm more excited
to see maybe them taking some time off
so that he can go make some movies where
he's not under like Disney training
wheels yeah like yes please go do what
you feel next like don't go do another
Black Panther movie go do what you want
and I feel like him even more than taika
I feel like he like the MCU is like or
you know five year whoever runs it
they're like uh just go make your movie
you know it's going to be great they let
Tyga Run free with a sense of humor and
stuff like that and you and I had a
whole lot of Chuckles watching yeah 411
Thunder but black panther will kind of
Forever by far yeah the best movie of
phase for the MCU absolutely and again
the difficulty level is always something
that's going to be and look what it's
going to do like this thing could give
Angela Bassett an Oscar nomination if
she gets an Oscar nomination out of this
she will be the first woman to ever be
nominated from a superhero type movie
and she will be the first non-villain to
be nominated from a superhero movie
because it's only Jokers Jokers Jokers
and Joker's been wild but now Jokers
Jokers Angela Bassett hopefully the
party it'd be well deserved what it is
84 the Tomato 84 certified fresh and 94
audience score again audience knows
what's up because that's a verified
audience score so that was actually
people that bought tickets to go see the
movie that that's what they said and
that was a lot of people over 600
million dollars so far so yeah dude you
know good stuff for the MCU in the pan
and still a pandemic where people still
have not really 100 come back to
theaters
um I have my my movie to wrap things up
here on part one of our two-parter the
top 10 movies for each of us of the Year
2022 is a movie that yes once again it
might speak to my heart and where I come
from but I also could not put a non-harm
movie in here some I mean I need a
horror movie I need something that
scares me Pearl X great double feature
by Ty West this year Maya goth but I'm
going with Barbarian just because it was
so cool so many twists so many turns and
it all starts with a premise you just
get to an Airbnb and you just hope it's
clean and oh there's a guy and it
happens to be Bill Skarsgard which you
should just left right then because that
dude always was suspect he's a handsome
man but he's got the Pennywise eyes he's
got the googly eyes but that's just the
start of the journey then we go
downstairs and I think on Airbnb it said
this was like a one bedroom there's a
lot more bedrooms there's a lot more
veterans in this house and then we pivot
so I could Justin Long Side Story that
we're like where is this the same movie
that it all ties up together it's 92
certified fresh 71 audience score and as
a fellow traveler of the world this one
it really gets you in the good spot
right I have kind of sworn off airbnbs
like I'm not not because of this movie
in general airbnbs have just gotten
really scary and like I'm like no I'm
staying at one uh next week really yeah
don't trust them haven't found a
underground dungeon with uh mutant
people just yet so it's a good movie it
is a really good movie I have uh I've
only seen a little bit of it I haven't
watched it all the way through okay okay
sorry how far in are you about I've
basically gotten just a little bit past
[Music]
no but I've definitely gotten down to
the rooms all right all right seem a
little cocky I mean I'm not saying I
know anything Twisted turns Jacqueline
twists and turn that's enough to know
that's enough to know it's good stuff
and I I love horror it's it's my
favorite genre to go see in a theater
opening weekend so I wanted to have one
I technically have horror-ish things on
my list because bones and all is
technically a horror horror romance I
mean rating people yeah yeah it's scary
uh
depends on who you ask so you can also
fall in love you could also fall in love
yes making it weird I don't need anyone
and maybe uh make sure you know who
you're marrying in the bedroom before
you actually tie the knot so we learned
a lot here as we always do on Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong those are really just
the star we're at halftime of our best
movies of 2022 we do not have a mailbag
today because we're too busy happy about
our favorite movies of the year but I
will say that we are going to turn it
over to you for the time being everybody
watching at home if you're listening
whether you're at the gym you want to be
like Jonathan Majors you do you but when
you're listening to it you always can
comment you can email us anytime RT is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com and let us
know what movies do you think we missed
but maybe you should just listen to the
other half of this
companion piece before you start yelling
about what movies we missed uh let us
know your thoughts on the movies we just
mentioned and episode two is coming
right up Jack when you uh you just want
to knock this thing out
yeah let's go okay all right well that's
Jack and Coy I'm Mark Ellis uh let's be
back that Jacqueline we'll see you tell
us live really we'll be back if they
don't know that by now
if you don't know where to find us by
now go back what's on the show next week
[Music]
laughs
[Music]